der frauenquote mit valentina maceri und
hat ähnlich wie den club auch mit dem
fußball zu tun und zwar st pauli also in
der zweiten liga die haben jetzt in
ihrem verein für wichtige positionen in
den gremien die frauenquote eingeführt
heißt 30 prozent sollen durch frauen
besetzt werden bei positionen die
präsidium aufsichtsrat und ehrenrat
sowie wahlausschuss viele bundesligisten
und auch zweitligisten überlegen
nachzuziehen ich sage das wäre ein
eigentor für den fußball und zwar weil
es darum gehen soll leistung zu
erbringen ich bin für das
leistungsprinzip das heißt gegen eine
quote wenn ich denke dass wir uns damit
keinen gefallen tun ja das denke ich
auch also das ist ja eine besondere
blase der politik correctness
unfassbar ich habe das nie mitbekommen
und bin ganz erstaunt dass es so was
gibt dann fordere ich umgekehrt hier
heute abend auch eine männerquote im
frauen fußball vereinen gibt einfach
haupt zu vielen männern die im
frauenfußball arbeiten wollen das gibt
es eine ganze menge da bin ich ganz
sicher
viele frauen die ehrgeizig auch im
berufsleben was erreichen wollen das
geht jetzt unabhängiger fußballs auf
welches jahr hätten spezielle das ist ja
es ist sicher es ist ja völlig in
ordnung dass es das gibt frauen in
männer fußballvereinen und umgekehrt
männer und frauen gibt es glaube ich
absolut wenig wenn sie nicht renner sind
gelegentlich aber doch gibt es auch so
aber da braucht muss man keine quote
haben sie finden ihren weg nach oben
wenn du was vom fußball verstehen also
ich zitiere mal den rb leipzig die
gesagt haben der frauenanteil bei ihnen
im administrativen bereich beträgt 35
prozent und der zusatz und den finde ich
ganz wichtig damit leben wir diversität
ganz natürlich und das ist ja genau das
was wir erreichen wollen meine
sekretärin wünschen nämlich leider auch
naturliebhaber ich als frau ich komme ja
aus also von klein auf hat mit drei
jahren angefangen fußball zu spielen ich
habe auf der straße mit jungs gekickt
ich weiß was es da heißt sich durch
leistung durchzusetzen und sich dazu
behaupten unabhängig vom geschlecht
nationalität herkunft und hautfarbe
übrigens das geht jetzt nicht nur für
das geschlecht und das zieht sich ja
durch mein ganzes leben so durch und
persönlich möchte ich nicht ernst und
wahrgenommen werden in diesem business
war schon oftmals schwer genug ist muss
man ja leider auch dazu sagen möchte ich
nicht wahrgenommen werden weil eine
quote zwanghaft dafür sorgt sondern ich
möchte ja für meine leistung anerkannt
werden das ist doch was heißt da mich
jedes mal das verstehe ich natürlich ich
meine sie sind so ein fighter auch so
street fighter haben sich da hoch
gekickt immer sind es leute ist und
wahrscheinlich noch noch nicht nur am
ball und sondern auch wahrscheinlich
gibt es auch mal anders zur sache also
insofern riesen respekt davor
gleichzeitig verstehe ich aber nicht
diese sorge von frauen
dass sie sagen also jede quote die wir
in anspruch nehmen mindert unsere
leistungsfähigkeit oder uns was uns
zugeschrieben wird an leistung weil dann
gelten wir nur als quotenfrau glaube gar
nicht wenn wir uns angucken was beim dfb
da los ist und jetzt auf das ist halt
nicht die fcl aber aber der dfb ist also
eine männerdomäne und donata hopfen ist
toll dass die das wird also auch ein
tolles zeichen auch ohne quote aber da
wäre eine quote vielleicht einmal
angemessen und würde da vielleicht dazu
führen dass das nicht diese zustände
gibt die wird er in den letzten 10
jahren gesehen aber darf ich ihnen da
entgegnen hat das warum sie es auch
nicht verstehen dass wir uns so fühlen
es weil sie es auch nicht nachempfinden
können das nur weil sie sind
hoch aber
ich meine als frau dass man zumindest
ich kann das jetzt im fußballbereich
sagen ist es schon oftmals so dass man
das gefühl hat ganz stark anfangs
zumindest unterschätzt zu werden nicht
wahrgenommen zu werden immer dann wenn
es wichtig wird nicht eingesetzt zu
werden sondern eher so ein bisschen am
rande mitspielt dann immer gut genug ist
aber wenn es drauf ankommt dann reicht
es nicht aus und dieses gefühl sorgt ja
dafür dass man diesen kampfgeist
entwickelt den sie angesprochen haben
dass man sich durch leistungen
durchsetzen möchte wenn es jetzt frauen
gibt die auf gewisse positionen kommen
aufgrund der quote die aber vielleicht
nicht mal kompetent genug sind oder es
gäbe einen mann der kompetenter wäre
dann tut man sich ja damit keinen
gefallen und schließlich ein eigentor
weil man setzt eine frau auf diese
position
aufgrund der quote bei man muss gerade
vielleicht keine andere frau hat die
genau kompetent sein könnte wie ein mann
die macht ihren job dann nicht gut und
dann stehen wir frauen im gesamtbild
wieder schlechter da das gilt aber für
jede quote überall was sie eben gesagt
haben gilt überall ich finde aber
speziell die der fussball
wir reden jetzt im moment die man dfb er
bräuchte er eine intelligenz quote oder
eine
jetzt haben eigentlich in jedem bereich
er
[Gelächter]
ich will erst mal auf das noch an
geeigneten diesen bogen um das weiter da
sein ist doch genau das was uns am ende
auszeichnet dass wir selbstständig durch
leistungen dorthin wollen und ich finde
es total stark dazu sagen ich möchte
nicht irgendwo durch eine quote besetzt
werden sondern weil ich mich dort hin
gearbeitet habe und man muss sich auch
hinarbeiten also möchte ich das ganz
genauso machen wie er und ich finde
immer und auf die politik zurückzukommen
ich bin ich bin kein fan von der
frauenquote vor allem bezogen auf die
politik ich halte nichts vom
paritätischen
ich glaube auch vor allem mit blick auf
die cdu bringen sie uns nichts wir haben
aktuell jetzt ungefähr 25 prozent
frauenanteil der cdu bundestagsfraktion
der cdu/csu bundestagsfraktion das
entspricht etwa dem anteil den auch in
der partei haben ist also für die partei
repräsentativ nicht aber für die
bevölkerung dazu ist aber der gesamte
bundestag einfach nicht repräsentativ
wenn wir die frauenquote innerparteilich
sprechen finde ich immer wieder für mich
das allerwichtigste argument dass
dagegen spricht ist die dann kommt
häufig dieses ja wir müssen frauen dazu
animieren unbedingt für dieses und
dieses amt zu kandidieren wir finden
leider kann ich glaube dass eine frau
sich durchsetzen muss um für irgendetwas
zu kandidieren weil wenn sie sich auf
dem weg dorthin nicht einmal durchsetzen
kann
sie merken doppelt und dreifach sie
mussten auch in ihrer völker natürlich
doppelt und dreifach liefern es war sie
da waren wo ein mann
äquivalent ich mich blind wir noch gar
nicht auf ihrer position entsprechend
den gleichen job oder den gleichen spiel
das gleiche spiel angebot hatte da kann
man natürlich sagen klar das bringt die
tasten von uns durch und nur die tasten
harten kommen in den garten am liebsten
kommentiert aber es ist doch auch nicht
gerecht wenn sie es vergleichen wollen
der leistung die andere einst ihr wollt
aber nicht wir wollen aber nicht nur
tafel im garten haben
es gibt bestimmte bereiche wo die quote
einfach gut und richtig ist dass waren
der politik so und das ist auch eine
wirtschaft so also in den aufsichtsräten
gibt es jetzt eine quote jetzt sind die
vorstände dran ich bin mal gespannt was
die neue koalition da vereinbart und da
will ich nicht nur die taffen in den
hosenanzügen da oben sehen die mit
flachen sohlen durchs leben laufen
sondern da bin ich ganz normale frauen
sehen und
gute freundin
sehr angesehene hirnforscherin die aber
im outfit von frauen rum läuft also high
heels und nette kleider und so weiter
die ist immer angeguckt worden als sie
vom mond es hat sich aber durchaus stand
ein ja aber wenn es eine quote gibt es
ein bisschen einfacher sich locker
durchs leben zu das muster auch die
männer in schutz nehme ich mir über
einen slider jetzt die männer
wahrscheinlich
hat man das klassenbewusstsein
angenommen
[Gelächter]
um dann nochmal auch auf die seite von
von ihnen zu springen anders ist
tatsächlich auch so dass viele frauen
auch nicht wirklich sehr weit nach vorne
stürmen wollen also ich rede jetzt
meinen fußballsprache die spielen immer
im abwehr modus das heißt wie sie gesagt
haben aufgrund der geschichte müssen wir
ja sowieso immer doppelt und dreifach
abliefern und tatsächlich ist es auch
einfach aktuell so dass es nicht so
viele frauen in führungspositionen aber
wahr ist auch ganz viele
gesellschaftliche gründe für ich würde
es gibt auch ich muss auch dazu sagen
zum beispiel du hast es ja selber gesagt
wenn man einladungen zu fußball talks an
frauen schickt bekommt man sehr viele
absagen weil frauen sich auch nicht
wirklich trauen dh wir sind ja schon
gefangen nicht bei null an sondern wir
fangen ja im minusbereich an das heißt
um in den plusbereich zu kommen muss ich
echt auf vollgas gehen ja aber da fangen
wir jetzt endlich jeder braucht seine
sendezeit ich weiß sie aber ich habe
diese runde werden wir beim wein
vielleicht noch weiter führen die
thüringer cdu darauf dass die
frage wo das einzige thema wo ich keine
meinung zu aber weder schon mal von mir
erlebt haben
[Musik]